if you found out your dead mother was
alive and deep within the earth's core
what would you do you will have to
journey to the center of the earth where
everything and anything will try to kill
you i'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the abyss itself in made in abyss this
little girl is about to go through
literal hell in order to find her mother
rico here is not your average little
girl she is a part of a group called the
red whistle orphan explorers they're
trained from a young age to venture down
deep within the earth's core a place
known worldwide has the abyss rico has
no idea that this unknown and barely
explored deep hole will cost her
everything she loves rico and her friend
are searching for lost relics near the
surface of the abyss when all of a
sudden her friend gets discovered by a
horrifying crimson split jaw worm that
is about to devour her friend right in
front of rico's eyes rico looking on in
sheer terror acts quickly by blowing on
her red whistle to get the absolutely
ginormous worms attention but it's at
that moment that she instantly regrets
her decision and gets tail whipped by
the worm down a shaft only to have to
continue running for her sweet life and
the monster is gaining on her and is
about to devour her flesh when all of a
sudden a huge blast is emitted right in
front of rico's eyes causing the worm to
fly away well that's just great that's a
crimson split jaw worm that is a type of
carnivorous scarlet red reptile species
that lives mainly in the third layer of
the abyss the fact that we saw it here
is insane and super rare and let's be
honest there's no way that we can beat
this beast because we're just 12 years
old in pigtails but part of this beast
diet does include ancient artifacts and
ruins and we noticed that that monster
ate that kid's backpack full of
treasures before it tried to attack him
and we've got a whole buffet full of
artifacts right in our bag so if i was
rico i would gracefully let our friend
get torn to shreds sorry but that
wouldn't have left us out of the woods
just yet the only way to get rid of this
thing for good would have been to throw
our bag full of artifacts away from
where we are while also retaining one or
two in our hands just in case the noise
of the bag dropping in the distance
would have gotten the split jaws
attention and we as a result could have
circled around the split jaw heading
back into the cave right near where our
friend was discovered realistically we
could not have outrun this monster for
long so our best bet would have been to
hide within that small cave since it is
unlikely that the split jaw could fit
through there the remaining few
artifacts in our hand could have been
used as a means of distraction in case
the worm caught onto our plants before
we could have reached the cave rico
looks around in confusion and notices
burn marks on the nearby trees whatever
that mysterious beam was was something
truly powerful and highly useful if we
can get it rico then notices a pendant
but not before she spots a young boy
near her age passed out nearby with his
hands glowing bright red rico sees that
this boy is nothing short of
extraordinary and discovers that he's
not a boy at all but a robot rico
wonders where in the hell did this
strange robot come from back at the
orphanage that rico lives in she begs
her climbing teacher to let her go
further into the abyss wanting to catch
up with her mother who disappeared years
back somewhere within the abyss but she
doesn't realize that she'll soon get
everything that she ever wanted and much
more later rico and her friends finally
managed to wake up the robot boy who
doesn't even remember that he is a robot
nor what his special powers are and who
cannot even remember where he came from
rigo ends up calling him reg and begins
showing him around the town suspecting
that he came from within the abyss since
duh she found him in it over time she
and her friend secretly make him a part
of the orphanage and he learns to live
the ways of red whistle explorers until
one fateful day changes everything for
him and rico a lift comes floating up
out of the abyss and out comes trusted
family friend of rico called beard guy
who announces that they found the white
whistle of the town's top explorer who
turns out to belong to rico's long-lost
mother the town celebrates the return of
rico's mother's whistle and a big
ceremony is given in her honor this is
where riko finds out that she was born
from within the abyss and that her bad
eyesight and glasses are direct result
of the curse of the abyss since there is
nothing actually medically wrong with
her eyesight rico also finds out that
her mother went on a long treacherous
journey to the center of the abyss
resulting in every one of her teammates
dying except for one person all the
while being pregnant and giving birth
down in the abyss bringing rico back up
as a baby from the depths of the abyss
in a curse-repelling vessel rico's
teacher over here also says that
ascending from the fourth layer of the
abyss is unbearable even for adults with
rico herself only making it back alive
as a baby thanks to the vessel her
mother and the one surviving member of
her squad put her in okay this is insane
if i was rico i'd focus less of my time
on climbing and more time on studying
the myths and legends and history
associated with the curse of the abyss
because if my eyesight was affected
enough by the curse to cause an eyesight
impediment for life then i'd personally
want to know if the curse gave or took
anything else from me and i would use
everything that i can from all known
realms of science or otherwise i'd also
ask around if anyone has ever looked
into formulating a suit made of the
materials that a cursed repelling vessel
is made of because it's clear that in
order to go into the abyss we're going
to need some help and right now the only
thing that gave us an edge over anyone
else is the fact that we have a strange
artifact from the abyss itself that
robot boy that we met reg i'd also get
some help from some trusted
knowledgeable friends and anyone that we
can find to begin examining reg asap
because if reg came from the abyss that
means he must know how to handle it
subconsciously or otherwise later rico
is given permission to reveal the lost
contents found within her mother's
belongings where inside she sees
in-depth guides on the various
undiscovered relics and animals found
deep within the cave and it's here that
she sees a drawing that looks just like
the robot kid reg and that's when rico
discovers something insane she finds a
note from her mother saying that she'll
be at the bottom of the abyss waiting
rico then loses her [ __ ] because
obviously mom's calling and plans to go
find her mother who now she thinks is
actually alive and calling for her rico
prepares for the most dangerous and
terrifying journey that she will ever
take and is warned by her high-ranking
peers that this journey to the bottom of
the abyss is too dangerous to go rico
decides to go anyway and reg also agrees
to go with her wanting to go down with
her to find out just exactly where he
comes from and claiming that he will
protect rico with his life rico's
classmates then plan out the route with
this glasses guy bringing out a map of
the abyss's sixth layer to netherworld
which shows everything of the abyss that
has up until now been mapped out with
the first layer being 1300 meters down
which is where they'll encounter
terrifying beasts from the second layer
coming up to greet them as they
themselves come looking for prey the
second layer will be when the strain of
ascending is said to become too
difficult for most people to bear and is
past the limit where any help from the
surface will be sent treating the second
layer and everything else past that as a
suicide mission the end of the second
layer will be when the immense unstable
air currents and savage monsters of
unknown origin will begin to appear the
third layer will possess an immense
vertical cliff over 4000 meters which
they'll need to traverse with the fourth
layer being only meant for high-ranking
black and white whistle explorers 7 000
meters below the fifth layer known as
the sea of corpses being white whistle
exclusive territory with less than five
white whistle explorers ever returning
from those depths and finally the sixth
layer from which no white whistle has
ever returned from that is where true
terror will await them in the abyss okay
first off i like fame and glory as much
as the next girl but the fact that
you're willing to go down they're
unprepared just off of an old note from
your mother is so stupid we have no idea
when this note was made so first i'd
make a case for us to begin examining
the note and ink from the paper it was
written on the chemical analysis of
writing and printing inks and matching
them together can be invaluable when
trying to prove whether a document is
fraudulent or not and in this case i
wouldn't risk my life for my mother
unless someone can prove to me beyond a
shadow of a doubt that it was written by
my mother and written by her
recently and we can do this by the
process of ink dating ink dating is a
highly specialized forensic examination
to determine the age of the ink and can
be formulated to identify a specific
manufacturer to ascertain the first date
of commercial availability and the
chemical solvents within the ink that
evaporate over time can be found and
traced through a technique known as gas
chromatography and or mass spectrometry
to determine if the written document was
created within a specific period of time
and if this puny little town didn't have
access to such things then i begin
sending that bad boy overseas to a
forensic laboratory first because you
heard what awaits us down in the abyss a
certain doom so we need to make sure
that we don't go down there purely on a
whim or a hunch because i love my mom
but i don't know if i love her that much
the big day of their horrifying
adventure has now come and the duo
sneaks past everyone and finds another
way down into the abyss they say their
goodbyes to their friends and descend
down into the blackened depths below and
this is where all the fun is about to
begin rico and reg reach the first layer
but get lost along the way with the
depth gauge indicating that they are 820
meters below sea level rico then runs
off to get a better vantage point
witnessing the first layer of the abyss
in all of its terrifying glory riko
thinks this means that at this speed
they'll make it to the bottom of the
abyss in no time at all greg and rico
stop to make breakfast for the day while
reg gives rico an envelope it's her
mother's sealed letters rico grabs a red
slip from the book written in her
mother's handwriting saying how departed
dawn to come capture you this freaks
rico out as she thinks they're running
late to meet her mother and because of
this they quickly clear out and begin to
descend even further down into the abyss
but that's when they run into a silk
fang reggae quickly shoots his robotic
arm at the spider as they make a jump
for it barely escaping with their lives
this is a silk fang a very common large
insect found within the first layer of
the abyss this bad boy is known for
paralyzing poison that it spits from its
mouth reg did well but failed to spot
the warning signs earlier that could
have prevented such a thing from ever
happening to begin with these creatures
are territorial after all and unlike the
split jaw worm they won't attack you
unless you enter their territory rigo
and reg should have noticed the warning
signs around them in the form of passing
through a 10 meter dome-shaped territory
which marks the zone where a silk fang
would be present to begin with this
creature rarely if ever leaves its dome
and frankly they could have completely
ignored stepping into their territory to
begin with if they just kept a better
lookout than descending willy-nilly not
knowing what's happening rico and reg
head further in but rico is already
feeling the effects of the harsh abyss
feeling lethargic and slightly weak as
they march further on into the depths
rico and reg then take a break but
that's when they hear a distinct noise
coming from within the bushes it could
be a search party that's after them so
the duo runs off at full speed knowing
that if they are caught they will be
forced to ascend back up to the top and
away from rico's mother but that's when
a huge burly man plunges down right in
front of them it's beard guy but luckily
for them he's not there to capture them
thanks to rico's friends they managed to
convince beard guy to come see them off
before they reach the second layer he
then gives rico some supplies such as
food and a vaccine vial meant to help
protect her from the effects of the
abyss the further down she goes he also
tells them of the white whistle who
helped rico's mom bring rico to the
surface as a baby ozen the immovable an
expert white whistle explorer who is
active deep within the depths of the
abyss beard guy then bids them farewell
and regal and reg descend further into
the mysterious depths of this
never-ending void okay this is insanely
stupid they shouldn't have just let
their only aid leave them so soon
despite this guy looking like harry
potter's shaggy uncle who knows
everything and also knowing everything
about this place and he's a black
whistle explorer which is the second
most experienced position besides a
expert mountaineer white whistle i would
have done everything i can to bout him
tighter to us than a wellington dinner
because this piece of [ __ ] isn't leaving
my sight now as rookie climbers we have
already studied the theory of the abyss
and all it contains but practical
experience is a whole different thing
than just a mere theory and beard guy is
ripe with practical advice and wisdom
that he can give to us remember we're
just a couple of snotty 12 year olds we
don't know [ __ ] first off i want more
information about this ozen the
immovable character and if she is
someone i need to worry about i'd also
ask more about the third and fifth
layers of the abyss because the fourth
layer will contain that 4 000 meter
vertical cliff and the fifth will only
be where a few whistles have ever
returned from this will make scaling
down such areas exponentially more
difficult compared to the second layer
rico and reg are still taking this
journey way too carefree and this will
cost them the scenery changes as the duo
descends further reaching an eerie bit
of grassland surrounded by a sinister
looking forest they just reached the
second layer of the abyss riko jumps up
and down in excitement while reg looks
more concerned knowing the harsh
realities of the situation after this
point no one will come for them they
will be all alone rico and reg decide to
head to the seeker camp located near
there but it's at this moment that they
hear a voice and it's crying out for
help they run at full speed getting
closer to the pleas of what seems to be
someone in trouble but in the abyss
nothing is as it seems they come across
the source of the cries for help which
turns out to be coming from a strange
creature of some sort as it feeds on the
corpse of a dead cave raider it's a
corpse weeper and reg prepares to kill
it but rico knows something is up and
thinks it's a trap and she's right as
another corpse weeper comes diving down
straight for rico plucking her from the
surface and ascending high up into the
sky reg tries to act fast and aim his
robotic arm but it's deflected by
another corpse weeper he tries again but
the same thing happens these creatures
know his every move and they attack rag
with full force striking terror at the
very heart of his robotic soul he's
running out of time he decides to turn
on his massive beam gun the same weapon
that saved rico at the very beginning
knowing that if he misses his weapon
could kill rico reg unleashes the full
force of his mighty unknown powers as he
fires his raging blast straight at the
corpse weeper lighting up the sky fiery
red forcing all the creatures to fly
away and freeing rico with reg having to
save her before she comes crashing down
that my good weebs is a very large bird
that lives within the second layer of
the abyss and this is why children
aren't allowed to go down to these areas
because rico and reg were way too naive
for their own good rushing off to the
cries of help without any thought put
behind it first if we noticed during the
second or third cry from the mysterious
voice right before they found the source
the sound of the cries for help sounded
almost raspy with almost a alien-like
inflection in the sound of the voice
much like the predator species when it
tries to mimic its prey at first glimpse
of the corpse weeper rico and reg should
have considered this person to be
already dead even if he wasn't because
rico is familiar with what this species
is and should have known from the very
first sighting that this species of bird
always hunts in packs especially during
breeding season and often drives prey
towards their colony to hunt them
together upon first glance riku and reg
should have run away from them using the
cover of trees as a defense gets being
picked off by these corpse weepers from
the air worst case i would have stayed
under the cover of forests and trees
forcing any nearby corpse weepers to try
and attack me within close proximity and
from the ground this way reg could have
subdued their wings from close range and
rico could have aided in blinding them
the corpse weeper's reliance on their
superb spatial awareness was the only
weak point that we could have
realistically harmed if we got them
close enough to us first yet again rico
is overzealous with joy and naive as to
the harsh realities of the abyss but
tells rake that she can help reg train
to use his powers more effectively but
suddenly a wave of sleepiness comes over
him forcing him to pass out reg suddenly
wakes up after a terrifying dream
finding out that he's been asleep for
two hours and that rico has lost her
notebook the duo continues on with their
journey reaching further into the dark
entrance ways into the abyss finally
reaching the point where everything in
the abyss is upside down even the
waterfalls with crazy winds forcing reg
to not use his grappling hand looks like
they're gonna have to start climbing the
normal way from here on out no more
shortcuts for them the two then discover
strange alien-like monkeys who throw
things at them which forced them to run
but the harsh winds caused them to crash
hard looks like this journey's gonna be
a lot harder than they thought they
continue on and eventually reach the
seeker camp a place where the force
field of the abyss is weaker and the
atmosphere is not as violent the seeker
camp has a telescope to monitor any and
all activity around the area rico and
reg approach the sinister looking camp
sitting in the midst of all the trees
but the lift is not working so reg
shoots his retractable hands to send
them up but is suddenly grabbed by a
pair of black gloved hands but these
hands are no ordinary hands they belong
to the famous white whistle ozen the
immovable sending the lift down the
shaft the duo then heads up not knowing
what awaits them at the top of this
scary looking place here they meet one
of the most famous white whistles of all
time and she recognizes who rico is owes
and the immovable towers over the two
kids and invites them into her place
rico then shows ozen her mother's note
telling her that this is the reason they
came here but ozin then just walks away
saying that they can rest here for a
while and she leaves the room the gang
gets some rest and meets up with ozin's
assistant blue-haired girl who shows
them around the place but it is here
that ozin meets them again and reveals
that the note with rico's mother's
handwriting is not actually written by
her mother ozin tells rico that her
journey is over and that her mother is
actually dead as is evident by her white
whistle to top off the shocking news
ozin says that she's also found rico's
mother's letters at her gravesite deep
below the abyss meaning that rico's
mother is actually dead what did i tell
you did i not say that i was skeptical
that rico's mother's handwriting was
real come on now if i'm rico i would
believe ozen from the get-go and call it
quits right here and now and then go on
a sweet relic hunt before heading back
up to my town we have no idea what's
further down below other than near
certain death i'd also beg ozen to give
us free training lessons and start by
inspecting reg thoroughly he is probably
the most powerful being in this world
and up until now rico has not spent much
time in figuring out just what he is
truly capable of she needs to stop
treating him like a friend and more like
a lethal weapon the max depth of the
abyss that we know of is between 13 000
to 15 000 meters deep in comparison to
the tallest mountain in our world mount
everest is 8
849 meters this dang hole is bigger in
size than mount everest if our mother
was alive i'm pretty sure she would want
us to save ourselves especially if we're
a little girl that's about to risk our
lives on a hunch ozen then leads the
shocked duo into her chambers where they
see this massive wondrous white box a
relic so unique that is not even in the
relic guidebook one that rico's mother
brought along it's the curse repelling
vessel it's a relic design to prevent
any of the side effects that one would
get if they ascended from the abyss it
was made to help creatures who are
unable to make the trip back to the
surface but ozin says that the relic
also did something else amazing that
whatever contents were placed inside the
box would begin to be embellished with
life rico then finds out that she was
born stillborn and that it was only when
her corpse was placed inside the relic
that she came back to life ozen also
tells riko in a twist that she actually
despises her and tells her that she is
nothing but a walking corpse and that's
when reg has had enough of her [ __ ] and
confronts her but that's when he made
the biggest mistake because ozen is more
god than mortal and she's about to
destroy both of them she's way stronger
than reg by far and she challenges him
to the death and reg does his best but
is no match for ozin's terror rico comes
running to raik's safety but is slapped
unconscious okay this did not work out
so good for them ozen is the top white
whistle there is and is over half a
century old and there's no way that we
can beat her being left to die in the
abyss years ago ozin received one and
eventually collected 120 000 men pins
artifacts embedded into her skin which
are first grade artifacts found within
the abyss which can enhance the user's
strength and longevity tenfold with just
a single pin this is the source of her
power and durability and the reason that
we can't beat her as easily as we think
if i was reg i'd give up fighting this
towering giant lady who could step on us
any day and retreat but not for good i'd
argue that the only way to beat her
would be the hail mary of a long shot to
go find more thousand men pins near the
bottom of the fifth flare by visiting
the only station where white whistles
can venture to within the fifth layer a
forward operating base known as idle
front here i think we'd have our best
bet in finding more thousand men pins to
collect first before coming back to
destroy this towering feminine
monstrosity or as noted by rigg's energy
beam we could try using that as a last
ditch attempt but this could only work
if we found some sort of way to surprise
ozen when she would be least prepared as
long as she doesn't know what powers
we're capable of just yet so a surprise
attack at a later date may be our only
option as for rico being stuck there
she'd be fine she'll be fine reg aims
his terrifying energy gun at ozen
preparing to destroy her here and now
but ozin deflects the ray beam causing
rake to think fast and aim it upward
blowing a hole in the wall reg battles
her with all his might blow after blow
but it's no use reg passes out again and
wakes up to a crying rico along with
some cave raiders who came in after
blue-haired girl called them in for help
in a shocking twist this turns out to be
all a twisted test done by ozin to test
their strength in order to see if
they're prepared for the harsh terrain
in the abyss that they'll soon encounter
reg also finds out from ozen that he
passes out every time he uses his laser
beam gun for exactly two hours and that
he's almost indestructible according to
ozen ozen then reveals that the grave
where rico's mother is buried is
actually empty and says that rico's
mother is still down there and this time
she's not messing with them later ozen
prepares to whip these kids into shape
and leaves them out in the forest saying
that for 10 days in the harsh wilderness
they'll be forced to survive to show
ozen that they've got what it takes to
handle the next few layers within the
abyss reg and rico get to work building
a fire and tent and learn the ways of
how to survive the harsh wilderness of
the abyss during this process ozen and
her team keep an eye on them learning
their weaknesses and strengths rico and
reg soon learn the ways of this
terrifying forest even managing to
capture this ghastly looking jungle
beast for dinner with some tricks and
some traps learning and preparing for
the harsh layers of the abyss that they
have yet to face down below the 10 days
finally passed as rico and reign make it
back to ozen's camp all withered and
battered by their adventures in the
forest they finally made it ozen then
welcomes them back with a dinner and
reveals to them how the passage of time
works differently the deeper in the
abyss you go with months on the surface
equating to mere weeks or even days deep
within the abyss this means that rico is
not crazy and that her mother could
actually be alive but ozin says to watch
out for the other white whistles on the
fifth layer of the abyss the deepest
lair that humans are currently capable
of going to including the reckless and
pure evil white whistle known as the
sovereign of dawn bondrewd the novel but
ozin thinks that rico's mother's note is
a fake and not actually written by
rico's mother due to the penmanship
being overly large and crooked okay
we've known for a while now that our
mother's note could be a fake since
there's no basis to determine what we're
holding is indeed real or not but ozin
is on to something here the study of
handwriting analysis is a way in which a
person's fine motor skills can leave
clues about the author's identity based
on a set of predetermined
characteristics which is what forensic
experts routinely do they have to
distinguish between style
characteristics and individual
characteristics which takes a lot of
training with people at max sharing
maybe one or two similar characteristics
but the possibility of sharing up to 20
to 30 characteristics is virtually
impossible this is the reason why no
one's handwriting is exactly the same
and can be identified by looking for a
wide array of individual traits from
letter form including the curves slants
the proportional size of the letters two
line forms including how smooth and dark
the lines are indicating pressure
applied to formatting including the
spacing between letters and words and
the margins a writer leaves empty on a
page and ozin could tell all of this
from a simple glance because if ozin was
with rico's mother for any significant
length of time then she probably could
have been able to tell rico's mother's
handwriting just what in the world is
waiting at the bottom of the netherworld
with rico's mother ozin wonders and this
is exactly what rico aims to find out
ozen gives them an axe weapon that
belonged to rico's mother and ozin heads
them off down into the third layer rico
and reg reach an empty gaping chasm
filled with horrifying winged beasts
known as madoka jacks while they look
for a way to descend down even further
greg then grapples another entrance with
his hook hands as he descends with rico
but then here's something terrifying
something is hunting for them reg looks
one more time towards the source of the
sound before rico calls him to explore
the cave further with these furballs
after which they reach an abandoned ship
stuck in between the rocks and explore
it before rico steps in something
sinister something that frightens her to
her core as she looks more closely to
see skeleton remains just then a madoka
jack or let's say mj attacks them before
reg saves rico this is it reg needs to
act fast but he's terrified of passing
out after using his blaster reg thinks
again if he wants to use it while this
monster comes for their flesh this bad
boy means serious business and catches
their prey while airborne usually
honestly rico should have seen the signs
or we should have say smelt the signs
because she stepped in their poop these
creatures aren't exactly the most
sanitary of creatures to begin with and
their nests are usually accompanied by
nearby feces that surround the area and
we know from ozen that reg is
indestructible but realistically his
winning bet is that energy beam gun of
his so i'd say that why don't we go
balls to the wall and jump inside mj's
mouth sliding down its esophagus and
getting cozy from inside the monster
itself insane thought i know but ozin
told us that he's indestructible and we
can't afford to miss because hello
everybody knows the insides of a monster
are way softer we hope and we know with
near certainty that the monster's bowels
won't dissolve us in the acid in the
process problem solved just then greg
aims his hand and hopes to god that he
doesn't miss and fires his ray beam
blaster decapitating the beast right
there reg then tells rico to hide and to
be on alert since reg knows that he's
about to pass out and riko prepares
herself to take on the horrors without
rag but just then another split jaw worm
finds them which forces the duo to run
for their life and turns out that it has
injuries on its body exactly where reg
shot it earlier meaning that this is the
same monster from earlier and that it's
been following them they barely escape
with their lives managing to squeeze
through a small shaft just as reg
finally passes out forcing rico to be
all alone but rico being young and
ill-equipped for these depths she
decides to explore the cave even further
taking an unconscious rag with her
exploring the various ventricular shafts
that this menacing cave presents to her
but then she suddenly smells something
sweet it's the smell of fruit and her
little tummy is rumbling rico runs to
trace the source of this smell but not
before she falls right into this hole
but it's no ordinary hole it's filled
with animal furball corpses and it's not
a hole but a stomach they're inside
anamak kagame and its fruit smell was a
trap to lure the fur balls in and now it
has rico but rico thinks fast and whips
out her knife puncturing a hole right
through this beast's belly and they
quickly expelled the creature's innards
and are now covered in the scent of
fresh fruit but that's bad news bears
because rico gets up and looks around
her and sees nothing but furballs and
they're hungry because she smells just
like their favorite fruit so rico runs
for her little life tugging unconscious
rag along with all her might as she
falls and crawls her way out of that
horrifying situation but just then
another split jaw worm pops up right in
front of them ready to eat their young
flesh so rico quickly hands reg who is
now wide awake a weapon and he charges
at the worm and defeats it causing them
to barely get out of another life and
death situation the duo exhausted then
head off and finally get one step closer
to reaching the bottom of the abyss and
now they finally reach the fourth layer
they take refuge in what appears to be a
tree surrounded by countless pools of
water covered by steam but then reg
senses something in the atmosphere
something is watching them rico suggests
they get the heck out of there but
that's when they see it the most
horrifying monster that they've ever
encountered an orb piercer rico and reg
stand paralyzed in fear and rico
mentions that they need to run armed
with quills that can pierce through
steel and laced with poison there's no
way that they can fight this orb piercer
head on rhaegar grabs rico and runs but
this beast is too quick for them and
slices their backpack they're gonna need
a new plan turns out their only weapon
given by ozin was dropped right next to
the orb piercer the beast then charges
at them again while rico hands reg an
umbrella-like shield defending
themselves at the last moment until
something goes horribly wrong it's rico
and she's been stabbed she then
collapses as the poison takes hold of
her and is trembling in pain reg now
knows that he truly can't beat this
beast not yet and so he whips out his
grappling hook and bolts out of there
with rico before the monster can get
them jeez this is an orb piercer these
creatures are herbivores by nature but
are fiercely territorial and defensive
over their territory a single orb
piercer has taken the lives of over 100
black whistles over the years and reg
royally underestimated this beast now
this thing has only one weakness and
that is its face with this organ being
part of their face that senses the force
field of the abyss but they made the
mistake in trying to run from the get-go
as it's clear from the ability to sense
movement that this beast knew our
movements from the beginning and because
of this reagan rico lost their only
weapon their blaze reap pickaxe that
ozen gave to them instead of running
rake should have wrapped his first hand
around rico and had her jump off the
platform and hang to stay out of harm's
way and then should have waited for the
orb piercer to charge at him remember
he's likely darn near indestructible
therefore he could have used this orb's
piercer momentum to his advantage
waiting for that beast to charge at him
before planting his pickaxe deep into
its organs near its face and killing it
then and there but reg is not out of the
woods just yet because rico's arm has
grown twice in size and she is dying
fast she begs reg to amputate her arm
but he gets scared if he doesn't do this
she will die reg finally gets some
robotic balls and whips out his knife
and begins doing the most horrifying and
necessary thing he's ever done cutting
off the arm of a little girl rico then
suddenly passes out and it looks like
she's not breathing causing reg to freak
out hard but that's when he sees someone
a weird fluffy looking creature named
nanachi who offers to help them out reg
doesn't trust her fully but he has no
choice and begins to follow this strange
creature back to her house at her place
we then find out that nanachi is a holo
and over the course of the next few days
nanashi helps restore rico back to
health and they in the process also meet
a strange creature who is also a hollow
a person who was once a human who
ascended from the sixth layer long ago
causing them to lose their humanity and
turn into a beast this is what could
happen to rico if they aren't careful
down there nanichi also shows reg some
new tricks and helps him go back to
fight the monster that nearly killed
riko the orb piercer and they intervene
right before this terrifying monster is
about to kill this lost explorer and so
reg with the help of nanichi manages to
grab a hold of this beast's organs while
shooting his grappling hooks to tie the
beast up and reg obliterates this beast
with the full force of his energy being
causing a massive orb of light to spawn
right in front of them followed by an
explosion and nanaji's eyes widen in
shock and awe now he did what we pretty
much suggested just changing it up a
little by using his blaster but we could
have been yet again a little more clean
on our execution with some bait now i'm
not saying that we should have used rico
as bait we shouldn't use rico as bait
however she's pretty much already dead
and by ignoring this puny human delver
he found a new companion better equipped
to help us on a journey who is also not
a tiny eight-year-old girl with glasses
yes this would be heartless but her
death would be a noble one and we could
use her half-conscious corpse as bait
against the orb piercer by laying her
down within the orb piercers territory
and waiting for the beast to show up and
kill rico then we could come up from
behind and take it down with our blaster
worst case we'd miss pass out and the
orb monster would try to crush our
unconscious body for two hours until we
awaken yet again for round two after
seeing reg's massive energy weapon
nanichi has one favor to ask him and
that is to kill her beloved hollow
friend this hollow beast however greg's
mouth drops open at this shocking
request we then also find out about nana
chi's past and that she and this hollow
beast friend of hers are part of an
experiment conducted by the twisted
white whistle sovereign of dawn bondrewd
the novel caused by experiments in
finding out what happens when someone
comes into contact with the curse of the
abyss after quickly ascending from the
sixth layer and that this experiment
caused nanichi's beloved best friend to
lose her humanity and become this
indestructible beast and force nanity to
change her form into what we see now reg
then thinks that she's alive due to her
response and being called by name but
the nana chi says that it's just a brain
reflex and that her hollow friend
actually longs to die but due to her
indestructible skin cannot die no matter
how hard nana chi tries but she thinks
that reg's energy beam is the only thing
that has the power to do it if reg has
the will the days pass as rico heals
more and finally reg prepares to kill
nanichi's best friend blasting her into
oblivion with pure raw power as she and
everything else with her evaporate into
nothingness nanachi then weeps for her
best friend causing reg to weep as well
he did it but it's not all bad news as
rico finally regains consciousness and
asks for nanichi to come with rico and
reg to find her mom and now with nothing
holding nanachi back and rico fully
healed the gang heads off further into
the abyss to find rico's mother the
cause behind reg's creation and to
reveal some answers as to the creation
of the abyss itself and if you want to
figure out the truth about your robot
self don't forget to like comment
subscribe and check out how to be
playlist down below and on behalf of
everyone on the team griffin the
narrator me the editor don the writer
have a happy holidays guys see you next
year